thank you
we love sharing stories of amazing Drew
gooders that's right do gooders with
punting my name and we teamed up with
the LEGO Group to Spotlight a 17 year
old who volunteers with a charity
um that's been helping families in
under-resourced neighborhoods for more
than a century oh wait until you meet
Hazel okay take a look
my name is Hazel and I'm a volunteer
with Children's Aid where kids like meet
follow their dreams and start their own
initiatives to help the community I saw
moms in the community struggle to find
their own child care so I decided to
start my own babysitting business I
offer a pay which you can option it's
more than just babysitting I've become a
mentor to some of these children and
thanks to the just ask me program at
Children's Aid I'm following my dream of
becoming a women's health nurse
practitioner I'm really passionate about
reproductive health and human anatomy my
dream is to open my own practice that
also offers the pay what you can options
for nearly 170 years Children's Aid has
ensured that kids in New York City's
most under-resourced neighborhoods have
excellent education and Health Care
social emotional support and strong
stable families and I love being a part
of that Legacy
foreign
do you mind helping me build this Lego
gift box while I ask you a few questions
yeah perfect okay
um hazel I really would love to ask you
about your babysitting service like what
what inspired you to do babysitting my
neighbor moved in with their young child
but I was raised with brothers so I
never had like a little sister or
anything so I wanted to hang out with
the girl however I noticed that the Mom
needed child care services anyways so I
decided to do pay what you can so that
it wouldn't be an extra burden on the
mother and we would both benefit
basically they're so amazing now may I
ask why do you want to be a nurse
um so to me being a nurse is a way for
me to still be social with my patients
and still get to know them and I
personally like working with Children's
Aid because right now I work as a just
asked me peer Health educator so we
provide health education to teenagers in
the community and to me education is the
best way to have the best health because
then you can prevent things from
happening in the future
you're only 17. have you always been
like this have you always been such a
good caring see the world gonna fix it
take care of everybody kind of person
being Christian and first generation I
dream American I've always watched my
mom give back so to me I was raised in a
community where we're encouraged to
serve others without expecting things in
return
so how is Children's Aid fulfilling the
needs of families in your community it's
a great outlet for teenagers and even
just families with all ages to get
services that you wouldn't even think of
so they have gardening and cooking
classes they have horseback riding they
have after school programs they have ESL
classes they're really amazing
the LEGO Group is celebrating the joy of
building and bringing families together
in a multitude of ways with their build
to give campaign and so they're going to
send 5 000 Lego sets to Children's Aid
community centers
um for children and family to enjoy
um and our show wants to personally
donate ten thousand dollars to the
Children's Aid organization as well
and I really want to thank you for
bringing this organization to our
attention and I'd love to keep
supporting it thank you
um also the audience is going to go home
with a hundred dollar Lego retail gift
card and a set of Lego classic prints
you can also make a difference at home
through their build to give initiative
all you have to do is simply build a
brick built gift you know you just make
one of these and then with the hashtag
hashtag build to give now through
December 31st 2022 the LEGO Group will
donate sets to children around the world
in Need You just photograph it post it
do it to the hashtag and a set will get
donated
are you your friends yes are you are you
here support Hazel
thank you to Children's Aid I just am in
awe of what you guys do and thank you so
much
[Music]